where do you find the ideas for your
stories I would say a lot of my stuff is
goes into like kind of the complicated
like a mentor-mentee relationship or the
brother relationship brothers
relationship those those dynamics have
always been a part of my life
partly because I never had a big brother
and then have a mentor so I'm always
investigating those things all the
female characters and all of my movies
are all very strong female characters
before it became a thing to put a strong
female there yeah because the muse comes
from one and that's my wife so all of
the carrot all every female character
comes from her so they're going to have
those traits and so usually how the
story and I'm an I'm an urban director
you know I'm in the urban genre I make
no apologies for that
I love the urban genre that's what I
grew up watching as a kid it's what I
still continue watching I love gangster
films my stuff though comes from a place
of authenticity and genuineness and also
from an emotional place I always say I
go behind the headlines so like for my
first three films I called them the
drive-by Chronicles and I took them
directly from a headline from a drive-by
shooting somewhere and then I created a
story of that because we don't get that
we get the headline but we don't know
how that family is reacted to that we
don't know how they're dealing with that
we don't know the repercussions in the
neighborhood of how they're dealing with
that there are so many different aspects
compelling storytelling and as a Latino
filmmaker I get sometimes get for
that but my thing is if you haven't
watched my films you can't judge me just
based on the genre I choose to tell my
stories if you've watched them and you
come across that way with that I'll even
question you then because I'm the writer
and I know what's gonna be phoning or
cliche or stereotypical and the genre
itself isn't it's how you approach the
characters and I couldn't get the actors
that I get if my stuff was stereotypical
because they're not getting paid a ton
of money to be there they're doing it
because they responded to the script so
that's where most of my stuff comes from
I just love LA I'm inspired by LA and
where I live and the pea
that I've been around I'm inspired by
the people that struggle to just get up
in the morning provide for their family
and go to bed with some sense of
accomplishment for the day or some
fulfillment with whatever that is that
they're trying to do I know I'm more
blue-collar that way
I'm consider myself a blue-collar
filmmaker because I didn't go to film
school I didn't learn that way I didn't
go to a fancy college to learn writing a
lot of interesting there's a lot of show
runners now that are working on these
urban shows or all they got writing
extry at a college I'm like how do you
even know this world and for your
average audience it's enough but not for
me but just might be why they're saying
no to having me direct because they take
a look at my reel and they're like oh
this guy's doing it for real we don't
want him around here but because that's
been the kind of the backlash I get but
it also just depends on on a lot of
times it's people's perception right and
you can do nothing about that I just can
write direct and tell the stories that I
want to tell in the way that I want to
tell them and if people dig it then cool
if they don't nothing I can do about
that
so sorry I'm having trouble figuring out
why would they give you backlash if you
know a neighborhood or you want to delve
deeper into a headline what what would
be the problem with that well I'll put
it this way let's say you're let's say
you have a job as a mechanic and you're
a decent mechanic you know enough about
cars to be a mechanic and you're put in
charge of hiring another mechanic are
you gonna hire mechanic who knows more
than you when they can only have two
okay okay that makes does that make
sense yeah it does
you're not gonna hire that guy you don't
want that guy in your garage he's gonna
take your job right and that's probably
wise because I'm not a writer to be in a
writers room I see myself running a show
I see myself directing shows I see
myself getting my own shows done
so I think for now with the nose I've
gotten from people that's what my wife
says you know and and she's very she
doesn't feed my ego or anything she's
like why are they gonna bring you're
doing it for real you got real people
you know I work with a lot of ex-gay
members she's like who are really good
actors it's not just having X gang
members to authenticate your work can
they act because I'm seeing a lot of
that now too I'm like okay that's great
he was just he spent this many years in
jail but he can't act so but Hollywood
doesn't care they think that well we got
him and he has a great story we're gonna
sell that that's I'm seeing a lot of in
TV right now and I'm kind of like
there's such a lack of authenticity and
when you know there's a lack of
authentic authentic is when they
constantly are saying how authentic the
show is oh that was my next question
what are some of the red but when you
when you see something and it's an urban
genre and then you go wait a minute I
can tell this is written by someone who
lived on a cul-de-sac yeah that's
absolutely correct that was I think
that's the rent the biggest red flag for
me is when they start talking about how
authentic it is or they start talking
about they start talking about
everything except the stories that
they're trying to tell because if it is
you get engaged in the storytelling
doesn't matter nothing else matters you
know and particularly in my community
like that's all that's talked about now
you know I love Ava Duvernay she's
someone I look up to because she did a
Q&A recently and she had on the director
of a film called and she's like I'm
not going to talk about all the social
and all the being on an asian-american
filmmaker let's talk about the movie
let's talk about the craft of telling
the story and that's not because you
know because you're a person of color
it's like you have to talk about some
type of issue when I'm a filmmaker it
doesn't mean I don't have an opinion
about things that are happening in
today's world but they're gonna creep up
in my films and they're gonna creep up
in genuine and in more subtle ways I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna I'm not going to
promote my stuff by a message
just not gonna do that I've seen
filmmakers that does personal doesn't
work and second of all it's a cheap way
of promoting yourself
you